Olha só essa descoberta. O número da
balança pode estar mentindo para você
sobre o coração. Veja bem, um estudo com
mais de 21.000 1000 pessoas mostrou algo
impressionante. Não é o quanto você pesa
que envelhece seu coração, mas sim onde
está essa gordura acumulando no seu
corpo. Pois é, é, a ciência descobriu
que aquela gordura escondida na barriga,
a famosa gordura visceral, é muito mais
perigosa do que a gordura que você vê no
espelho. Ela fica ali no meio dos seus
órgãos e acelera o envelhecimento das
artérias. E tem mais, gordura infiltrada
no fígado e nos músculos também
envelhece o coração precocemente, mesmo
que a balança mostre um número
aparentemente normal. Sabe o que isso
significa? Aquele IMC que todo mundo
usa, que todo mundo adora, ele pode
estar te enganando. Uma pessoa pode ter
um MC normal, falsa magra, mas pode
estar cheia de gordura visceral
perigosa. Por outro lado, alguém com MC
alto pode ter gordura armazenada em
lugares menos prejudiciais, tipo lutador
de sumô. como coxas e quadris que nas
mulheres até protegem o coração. Então,
para de se obsecar com a balança, mede
tua cintura, faz exames metabólicos de
verdades, faz umaometria e presta
atenção onde teu corpo tá guardando essa
gordura. É isso que vai te dizer onde tá
a saúde do teu coração de verdade.